there's this thing that's happening you
know and obviously I've been in it my
whole life you know since I was four
yeah and you know first of all I'm so
proud of you you know I have I I see you
sometimes and we give each other hugs I
say I love you but I don't get to say
how proud I am of you I've seen you my
whole you know for years and on behalf
of my mom too because I know how much
you love her and I know how much she
means to you
and I know how far you've come I know
how far you've come because I remember
when you first stepped at the store and
I remember seeing you in Boston and I
remember because we're the same age and
we came up at the same time yeah and I'm
so proud of you dude and when I saw you
on that when I saw you on that stage at
MGM when you worked with Chappelle I was
like this guy's [__] funny